et le monde de la bd a perdu le créateur
de michel vaillant jean graton est
décédé à ce 21 janvier à 97 ans michel
vaillant était sa principale la série
une saga familiale dont il a signé 70
albums auteur et dessinateur jean graton
aura marqué la bande dessinée mais pas
que marc bourgne dessinateur et
scénariste yves les noix nous en parle
il a participé au dessin de six albums
de la nouvelle saison et nous présente
cet artiste novateur et d'avoir un coup
de pinceau assez extraordinaire il ancre
et ou au pinceau par les graphistes les
dessinateurs sauront de quoi je parle
enfin c'était un dessinateur qui étaient
sous-estimés parce qu'on a tendance à le
dire que ces personnages avaient tous la
mâchoire carrée il y avait tous un peu
la même tête mais mais il faut voir il
faut étudier attentivement son graphisme
pour voir la force qu'il avait et le
l'innovation aussi dans le traitement de
la vitesse le traitement du mouvement et
la narration fin c'était un très grand
auteur de bandes dessinées qui marquera
l'histoire de la bdl qui a créé en plus
un personnage mythique qui qui est sorti
des cases de bande dessinée puisque
michel veillon il ya eu des vaillantes
qui ont couru au mans un personnage
mythique donc y aurait en fait dépassé
les barrières de la bande dessinée avec
une grande notoriété notamment dans le
milieu du sport automobile